it started off really organically and I
could not have been more grateful to
have that relationship at that time
Vanessa Hudgens is taking a sweet stroll
down memory lane reflecting on her
relationship with Zac Efron whatever
happens as long as we're together it's
cool right the 30 year old actors opened
up about her ex on the awards chatter
podcast and revealed how grateful she is
to have dated her high school musical
co-star especially when she was
navigating her newfound fame from the
Disney show it was like this massive
phenomenon all the sudden and eyes were
on me and I it's just a really foreign
weird thing to go through and by being
in a relationship I feel like it kind of
kept me stabilized and grounded and I
had someone to lean on who was going
through it as well but Vanessa admitted
her relationship with Zac whom she
starred in all three High School Musical
movies with was complicated
I remember one time we did have a fight
and it was while we were at rehearsals
and I remember Kenny Ortega coming
around the corner with the most
concerned look on his face like oh no is
our movie going to fall apart right now
like I said I pride myself on being a
professional so I was like that aside
we're just gonna move forward and do
what we need to do and we sorted it all
out but yeah I I think because I was so
young having that relationship really
stabilized me the two reportedly began
dating a year after the first film was
released we had more fun making this
movie than anything yeah it's it was so
much fun to make and I think it really
comes across on camera it's a good time
but called it quits in 2010 after about
four years together she's a great girl
the two have since moved on and dated
other people vanessa is with Austin
Butler who get this was in the high
school musical spin off shar peis
fabulous adventure how do you guys stay
together
what's the court
I think you just have to it's important
to put that other person first and and
so if you're constantly looking for ways
that you can make them happy and they're
constantly looking for ways that they
can make you happy then you kind of lift
each other up as much as possible and
and then you can't go wrong I don't
think as for Zach he's enjoyed playing
the field do you believe in love at
first sight I think so 100% it's a good
thing to believe